e
Montréal et les montréalais
seraient prêts à un tel système
de récompense?
Voici mon reportage.
- Biggest city issue with bike
lanes are cars parked in...
- Pas d'inquiétude pour
ce cycliste new yorkais,
c'était orchestré pour
une démonstration. Il a testé
l'idée d'un conseiller
municipal : donner à un citoyen
dénonciateur, 25 % du montant
de la contravention pour
les véhicules stationnés
dans les pistes cyclables.
Des blocages que l'on constate
fréquemment sur les pistes
montréalaise
- Bien, aujourd'hui j'en ai
eu quatre ou cinq à devoir
contourner.
- C'est sûr que c'est un risque
pour nous parce qu'on doit
dé à à à à gauche, des fois
c'est pas toujours évident.
Donc on arrête puis on attend,
ou on fait autre chose là.
- Avec plus de 1000 constats
d'infraction à 173 $ depuisle 1e
la vis aux contrevenants.
- Sur les pistes cyclables,
on a zéro tolérance.
- Est-ce qu'on pourrait imiter
New York et payer les citoyens?
LAURENT CHEVROT, directeur
général, Agence mobilité durable
- Je suis pas persuadé que
dans la culture de la Ville
de Montréal, la dénonciation
des contraventions pour
avoir une rémunération,
ça soit quelque chose
qui soit aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des gens.
- Ah oui, oui! C'est une bon
idée pour moi, oui!
- Bien, pourquoi pas!
Je serais pas contre!
- Super idée! Super idée,
on devrait faire ça ici!
- Pendant ces trois heures
de chasse aux délinquants,
notre testeur new yorkais aurait
pu récolter 350 $. Vélo Québec,
ici, est préréréréréticent.
JEAN-FRANCOIS RHEAULT, PDG,
Vélo Québec
- Bien, les gens de New York
sont toujours un peusssss
là, mais ça reste avant tout
une responsabilité des autorités
compétentes. Demander aux
citoyens de jouer à la police,
c'est pas une bonne idée pour
plein de raisons.
- La Ville de Montréal ne
rejette pas complèteme
la proposition, mais...
SOPHIE MAUZEROLLE, responsable
transport, Comité exécutif Mtl
- C'est une idée intéressante.
C'est compliqué dececececececer
parce que ce genre de mise en
oeuvre-là, ça a des incidences
juridiques, t'sais, bon,
ça demeure complexe à mettre
en place donc...  C'est une idée
intéressante, mais je pense pas
qu'on en est là pour l'instant.
- Comme cette cycliste,
pas trop séduite par l'idée.
- Non, non c'est pas moi ça,
jelàlàlàlàlàlà pour ça moi,
désolée!
- Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréa